why the social worker exam needs to
change and so we have social work great
social workers of color who came to
Social Work schools to serve their
communities and they they're not being
allowed to do it despite rigorous
preparation at school Mass is among
those who have pushed the Association of
Social Work boards which for decades has
administered the exam to release pass
rate data and the results were Stark
between 2018 and 2021 76% of white test
takers passed the bachelor's level exam
the first time but only 60% of Asian
test takers did followed by 53% of
Hispanic applicants and only 33% of
black test takers passed that first time
exams don't exist to diversify they
don't exist to be inclusive they don't
exist to be welcoming they exist
specifically to narrow they are supposed
to have a narrowing effect